[Música]
bueno
vamos
[Música]
hola muy buenas noches estoy muy feliz
de estar acá en matamoros por primera
vez participando en mitre en mi primera
técnica y después de ella cuatro meses
de que fue primero de julio pues hoy
vengo a contarles mi experiencia de que
fue lo que yo gane al perder en las
urnas en mi primera elección pero antes
me gustaría contarles por que empecé a
hacer política en primer lugar y por qué
decidí que me quería dedicar a la
política para demostrarles que a veces
la política o la iniciativa de querer
participar nace de temas muy personales
que te mueven que te duelen pero que
también te pueden inspirar tenía diez
años cuando tuve el primer contacto con
una campaña electoral
mi mamá participaba coordinando la
campaña de mi tío al presidente
municipal en un municipio rural muy
distinto a una ciudad en la que había
crecido eso de chihuahua y era un
municipio de no más de 600 personas no
entonces una que era una campaña rural
aquí está muy distinto al contexto de
ciudad en el que yo había crecido y creo
que ahí me di cuenta lo importante de
los procesos electorales al haber estado
en contacto pues con todas las personas
que estaban participando en la campaña
las personas que iban a los mítines me
di cuenta que las campañas electorales
en este país sirven como un espacio de
esperanza de tener elecciones que nos
emocionan de tener representantes que
por fin puedan hacer algo distinto de
que las cosas por fin cambiar después me
interese más en la política porque era
de las primas que durante la cena de
navidad en lugar de estar con los primos
me sentaba en las mesas donde los
adultos discutían de política porque
siempre entendí que cuando se hablaba de
política se hablaba del país y que
cuando se hablaba del país evidentemente
se hablaba de lo que yo más amaba
también me di cuenta que quienes
generalmente hablaban de política eran
esencialmente hombres pasó el tiempo
entre la preparatoria
participe dentro de la política
estudiantil fui vicepresidenta de mi
preparatoria y hacíamos lo que hacía
cualquier organización organiza
asociación estudiantil organizar la vida
estudiantil procuramos fondos para
visitar el interior del estado para
hacer visitas a la comunidad y fue ahí
donde pues entendí por qué se empezaron
a acercar evidentemente partidos
políticos a lo que estábamos haciendo me
di cuenta que la única forma de hacer
política fuera de las aulas y fuera de
digamos este espacio que es la política
estudiantil tenías que hacerla solo a
través de un partido político
evidentemente nunca me sentí
identificada por ningún partido político
y más en un estado de en chihuahua en
donde hay de dos sopas no no me sentí
identificada también entendí que quienes
hacían política pues eran personas que
lucían de cierto modo no hombres de más
de 50 años que visten de traje que
hablaban cierto lenguaje y pues yo nunca
me sentí digamos representada para estar
en nuestros espacios se vino la decisión
de entrar a la universidad y con eso la
decisión de estudiar comunicación porque
creo que en un país tan violento y tan
desigual como el nuestro
periodismo me parece que siempre ha sido
una herramienta fundamental para hacer
llamar a rendir cuentas a los poderosos
así que digamos que decidí no hacer
política institucional pero veía en el
periodismo una manera digamos de seguir
incidiendo en la vida pública de mi país
empecé estar en la universidad empecé a
trabajar en un periódico como co editora
pero digamos que la inquietud de seguir
haciendo cosas políticas pues nunca me
abandonó me empecé a involucrar todas
las tardes y todos los fines de semana
en colectivos en temas de movilidad me
tocó salir a marchar para que cesara la
violencia me tocó participar en
asambleas feministas me tocó estar en
contacto con organizaciones que
trabajaban con población infantil que
vive en la calle y esencialmente lo que
me empecé a dar cuenta es que la
sociedad civil en este país resiste todo
el tiempo y lucha todo el tiempo y el
gobierno y sus instituciones responden
muy poco
después se vino 2012 que creo que es una
época que me atrevería decir que muchas
personas de este salón quizás le tocó en
algún sentido y creo que este año
nuestra generación yo tengo 28 años
nuestra generación topo comparece nos
dimos cuenta que participamos o no
participaremos alguien siempre iba a
ganar una elección alguien siempre iba a
ocupar un curul y alguien siempre iba a
tener acceso a presupuesto público y que
esencialmente esas personas que ganaban
elecciones que ocupaban curules y que
tenían acceso al presupuesto público no
les motivaba hacer política lo que a
nosotras que estabamos digamos fuera de
las instituciones nos llamaba a hacer
política la posibilidad de construir un
país distinto la posibilidad de que las
mujeres pudieran caminar sin miedo por
las noches durante las calles y la
posibilidad también quizás de que mi
generación volviera a tener una pensión
de seguridad social como si la tuviera
nuestros padres
así que pues un grupo de jóvenes
valientes con los que hoy sigo haciendo
política nos empezamos a reunir
alrededor de alrededor de la idea de no
podemos seguir delegando la política a
las demás personas esta foto de arriba
es digamos nuestra de las primeras
reuniones que estábamos teniendo en la
ciudad de mexico
para organizar un partido político eso
fue en 2013 pronto nos dimos cuenta que
hacer un partido político en este país
es muy complejo para participar
políticamente en este país o eres un
lobo solitario a través de una
candidatura independiente o partido
participas a través de un partido con
todas las ventajas y las desventajas que
se implica eramos no más de 20 personas
que estábamos muy centradas en el tema y
nos dimos cuenta que no teníamos la
experiencia ni la capacidad para
participar a través de un partido
político pero se aprobar las
candidaturas independientes y dijimos
bueno no vamos a desistir de la idea de
hacer política y de participar para
recuperar las instituciones pero lo
vamos a hacer a través de una
candidatura independiente nos
organizamos impulsamos la primera
candidatura en el congreso de jalisco
independiente de pedro como moto
y ganamos
esta fue una fotografía de 2015 que dice
como bromeando que se parece más a un
concierto de café tacuba pero en ese
momento
me tocó estar desde las 3 personas que
estuvimos de tiempo completo en esa
campaña y las cientos de voluntades que
hicieron posible que llegáramos al
congreso local sin deberle nada a los
poderosos tuvimos cerca de 20 mil pesos
de dinero público lo demás lo recaudamos
de dinero privado hicimos una campaña
austera colectiva que estuvo en la calle
que emocionó a las personas y que sacó a
57 mil personas a votar
a partir de ahí me tocó estar digamos
tras bambalinas estuve tres años
participando también dentro del equipo
de piel de pedro a través de una
convocatoria abierta y junto con él seis
personas que estuvimos en este pequeño
equipo en una sala j-2 en el congreso
del estado de jalisco hicimos lo
impensable hicimos que las personas
conocieran a su diputado impulsamos una
iniciativa a nivel nacional llamada sin
voto no hay dinero que logró por lo
menos en jalisco reducir el
financiamiento a los partidos políticos
y también fuimos la diputación mejor
evaluada
y frente a eso pues nos dimos cuenta que
teníamos que continuar que valía la pena
estar en esos espacios de toma de
decisión desde una desde una política
que no le debiera nada a los de siempre
y que tuviéramos la libertad para hacer
así que empezaron las reflexiones sobre
qué es lo que seguía y fue cuando yo
levante la mano para ser candidata
también al congreso local sin partidos
políticos por muchas razones pero una de
ellas tenía que ver con que estoy
convencido desde hace muchos años que el
cambio político en este país va a venir
de muchos procesos y por muchas redes y
por muchas acciones pero una de ellas
tiene que ser que más mujeres estén en
los espacios de toma de decisión y no
sobre la fotografía esta es una foto de
me invitaron a una preparatoria no se
alcanza a ver muy bien pero me parece
una foto poderosa no porque esté yo ahí
sino porque no sé si alcanzan a ver pero
es básicamente una fotografía del
gabinete presidencial de este sexenio
donde evidentemente son hombres que
lucen de cierta manera que son blancos
que parece que sólo se representan
mismos y pues al frente estaba un grupo
de chicas de la preparatoria que me
invitaron a hablar sobre mi experiencia
haciendo política creo que la condición
de posibilidad para que este país tenga
una transformación política va a tener
que ser cuando más mujeres estén en las
portadas de los periódicos dando
declaraciones estén discutiendo el
presupuesto y sean también las que
porque no estén al acá al cargo de la
seguridad de la paz en nuestro país así
que con este digamos impulso feminista
que me ha acompañado por mujeres que
quiero y por mujeres que he conocido en
el camino pues me lancé en la aventura
de ya no estar tras bambalinas y me tocó
ser parte de una de las voceras que
estuvo al frente de la red de
candidaturas vamos a reemplazarlos en
varios estados del país y yo contenta
para una diputación local en el distrito
10 es por el spoiler aller perdimos la
elección pero después de nueve meses de
estar en las calles de visitarlos jiang
y de tocar casa por casa y de obtener
casi un millón de votos en todo el
estado esto es lo que yo he aprendido en
el camino
de entrada creo que la crisis de
representación en este país no se
resuelve sólo con una figura
presidencial creo que las personas que
nos quieren representar en los
ayuntamientos y en los congresos locales
tienen el imperativo de no soltar el
territorio por algo fundamental que
tiene que ver con que es necesario que
conozcan sus calles es necesario que
conozcan sus territorios
yo lo contaba con los vecinos y vecinas
del distrito con el que me tocó
conversar prácticamente durante los tres
meses que estuve haciendo campaña y yo
lo que les decía es que nosotros quienes
hacemos política pues no somos ingenuos
evidentemente hay una crisis de
desigualdad muy potente en este país
violencia en este país yo lo viví en
carne propia salí de chihuahua cuando
tenía 18 años y ser mujer y ser joven
era prácticamente una actividad de alto
riesgo y todo eso lo sabemos de verdad
lo tenemos muy claro pero cuando lo
escuchas de los vecinos cuando los
escuchas de los estudiantes cuando lo
escuchas de los abuelos y las abuelas
que no les alcanza para pagar la pensión
la empatía crece porque algo yo tengo
muy claro y a pesar de que estuve en una
local no era yo la persona que estaba al
frente pero entendía a través de pedro
que hacer política institucional es muy
complejo las inercias son muy potentes
las instituciones y sus malas prácticas
llevan más de 60 años lubricando hacia
sí mismas y qué hacer entre otras cosas
tener tus convicciones muy fuertes y
esas convicciones florecen cuando
construyes un pacto de
corresponsabilidad con las personas con
las que hiciste campaña y después de
nueve meses nosotros estuvimos haciendo
pedagogía política no algo que yo
también aprendí es que las campañas
electorales deberían ser menos espacios
de autopromoción personal y más un poco
más espacios de hacer pedagogía política
durante todas las reuniones vecinales
que yo tuve con los vecinos y las
vecinas de zapopan yo pasaba quizás allí
también fue un error yo pasaba menos
tiempo hablando de lo maravillosa que
era yo para representarles y más tiempo
hablándoles de por qué el sistema de
justicia no funciona en el nivel local
porque las reglas de los ayuntamientos
funcionan para privilegiar los intereses
de pocos sobre la construcción de
ciudades que deberían ser más amigables
les explicaba con lujo de detalle porque
el sistema de cuotas de partidos y las
designaciones entorpecen los procesos de
justicia en nuestro país y frente a esto
evidentemente construye es un proceso de
largo plazo porque ya no sólo tiene que
ver con lo maravilloso que es cierto
candidato a cierto candidato o candidata
para ocupar un puesto pero también
construye es ciudadanía y creo que eso
es uno de los legados más importantes
esta es una fotografía pues me parece
muy simbólica porque no perdíamos tiempo
al hacer campaña y aquí es un claro
ejemplo de eso
y también es importante entender que
estos procesos de pedagogía ayudan a
construir una relación cívica entre
representantes y representados una
relación que lleva décadas completamente
fracturadas y porque apostarle a esta
relación porque necesitamos recuperar la
confianza en las instituciones porque en
un país tan desigual como el nuestro no
va a haber suficiente albergue de la
sociedad civil que dé cabida a todas las
mujeres que son violentadas en sus casas
porque no va haber albergues suficiente
que dé cabida a tantos niños y niñas que
son hoy abandonados en sus casas
necesitamos que en un país desigual como
el nuestro las instituciones funcionen y
para eso tenemos que construir pactos de
corresponsabilidad con las personas que
nos están votando ésta es una fotografía
de a mí uno de los eventos preferidos
que tuvimos en campaña y ahora una
especie de pues un festival no a mitad
de campaña y teníamos círculos donde
vecinos nos no se entrevistaban o con
una especie de entrevista de trabajo y
todos los candidatos y personas a su
alrededor estaban digamos cambiándose
asiento tratando de pues cuestionarnos
al respecto de cuáles eran nuestros
planes
si es que llegábamos al congreso local
definitivamente algo que también aprendí
y que creo que para mí es de los mayores
aprendizajes después de nueve meses de
los nueve meses más intensos de toda mi
vida es que reafirme la convicción que
yo tengo de seguir haciendo política
pero una política colectiva y creo que
estos nueve meses me enseñaron que es
muy importante tener claro por qué haces
las cosas no y yo lo tengo muy claro no
lo hago política porque no me siento
representada en el congreso local yo
hago política porque he visto de cerca
cómo utilizan el presupuesto sin
indicadores y para que se vayan los
espacios menos prioritarios y recuerdo
que en las reflexiones cuando levante la
mano para ser candidata pues
evidentemente fue un proceso complejo no
imagínense siendo una mujer en ese
entonces tenía 26 años sin partido
político digamos había estado tras
bambalinas de un proceso político
evidentemente pues tenía cierta
desconfianza
y recuerdo que una amiga me obligó a
hacerme la pregunta susana para qué
quieres hacer política porque les digo
el por qué lo tengo muy claro no hay
muchas cosas que no me gustan y es lo
que me mueve a hacer política pero
digamos que cuando estás en procesos
complejos que tienen que ver con hacer
política hacer participación ciudadana
organizarte con tus vecinos para
transformar la realidad
tienes que tener muy claro para qué
quieres hacer política yo ese para que
digamos que lo sigo construyendo en cada
asamblea de mi organización en cada
entrevista en cada debate en cada
reunión vecinal y hoy más o menos lo
tengo claro no y parece obvio pero creo
que es importante preguntarse lo yo hay
yo hago política para que mi país sea
poco más justo y más equitativo de lo
que soy y creo que ese para que me ayudó
a entender que a pesar de la derrota se
que nuestro proyecto tiene futuro porque
me para que nunca fue que susana llegar
a un curul y para que nunca fue que
susana estuviera en la nómina del
congreso del estado de jalisco y para
que es muchísimo más amplio y si llega
él era un medio para llegar ese para qué
pero al final creo que en política y de
entrada a cualquier movimiento social
pues los procesos nunca van en la
ascendencia no tienen que tener ciertos
picos de inflexión y al final creo que
nos hacen crecer
tengo claro el por qué el para qué y el
cómo quiero hacer política pues también
no quedó completamente reafirmado en la
universidad yo utiliza a veces como a
través del periodismo pero hoy estoy
convencida que yo quiero hacer política
con las personas que hice política
durante estos nueve meses personas que
quiero que admiro que me levantaron el
ánimo y que quiero compartir todos mis
talentos todas mis experiencias y todas
mis energías para transformar junto con
ellos no sólo intentar transformar este
país
finalmente que creo que debe seguir para
los movimientos sociales o movimientos
políticos incipientes porque yo tengo
muy claro que esas 15 personas que
empezamos hace cuatro años también
quizás aquí hay en kim en matamoros 15
personas que están dispuestas a
organizarse con la gente que quieren
para poder transformar su realidad y
creo que frente a la polarización que se
vive nuestro país la mejor herramienta
contra el fascismo es el diálogo es la
generosidad es la empatía algo yo
aprendí algo de las cosas más potentes
que yo aprendí en campaña es que
el sentido común que a ti te parece un
sentido común y las ideas que tú crees
que son la correcta quizás al otro no le
parecen las correctas pero al final la
política es eso una herramienta que nos
permite empujar las ideas pues que
permitan tener un consenso entre todas
las personas también creo que va a ser
muy necesario que personas jóvenes y
mujeres sobre todo no dejen de aplicar
para estar en los espacios de toma de
decisión eso es fundamental y que no
suelta en el territorio el territorio y
finalmente creo que la política radical
que creo que necesita este país para
oxigenar su vida pública tiene que ver
con una política que esté cercana a
principios de democracia de austeridad
de rendición de cuentas y creo que esa
es la política que este país necesita la
política que nos puede tener que acercar
a tener un futuro mejor
muchísimas gracias ahí finalmente les
enseña una fotografía si se fijan empecé
con la fotografía de un abrazo y terminé
con una fotografía de un abrazo
algo que creo que toco mucho en nuestra
campaña es la política de los abrazos la
política de la alegría y creo que
mientras sigan existiendo este tipo de
gestos hay futuro para nuestro país
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]